conscious officer news in Puget areas
who's recently seen perched a lotta
tourism be removed wanna escape lava to
Minnesota so the Prytania server
potassium Mucha dementia teaching
[Applause]
[Music]
from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in the eye my eye fro is picky to
the night east maschino and Versace nice
no laces inner Archie's new millennium
this is a video I uploaded in 2015 on
YouTube however I'm reapplying it
because it shows the importance of
people being slandered specifically
sisters falsely and this very
documentary I had to travel to France to
document a 14 year old girl literally
committing suicide because of false
allegations on false video circulating
about her I'm bringing this back
sunlight inshallah cause it's very
important not only do sisters get
sounded brothers also but sisters suffer
greater consequences sadly and this is
against Islam and allah subhanaw taala
talks about this very severely please
watch this video in shala and share it
to raise more awareness
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Reggie Reggie what makes this incident
so significant you know even so just
that has to occur if like me there's no
one even else yeah to be honest yeah cuz
I really wanted to do this project
because he sees rather is something
really
the Quran speaks very harshly of it in
order to keep that slander against those
believing men I believe in women they
punish me so severely as well so it's
learn the plays a big role in society
and people just do it like that is
nothing but they don't understand the
damage it causes and one of those
damages is like the sister you know that
has commit suicide maybe it was only her
keys or many people have heard stories
in Canada you know I've heard stories of
sister saying my once my brother dragged
me into the car beat the crap out of me
because right because somebody called
went and said oh no sister did they said
that no proof no evidence he said she
said so this is something that you need
to learn from enough for you know what
if it needs us to go to France together
as a team we have to go you know it's so
important that even brother Imran might
be catching a plane to come help us with
a Charla okay
when you release the poster saying she's
passed away now you know the
[Music]
consequences of slander but my main
objective my main objective is that but
I'll only obviously want to build
solidarity for the sista from looking at
building maybe a couple of water wells
and some olive trees in Gaza so you know
inshaallah saw the sisterhood benefit
from the hair off that UV I'm trying to
say so that's one of my objects is what
we do we just don't want to put this we
don't want to just brush this under the
carpet and you know everybody forget it
yeah you know I wouldn't put it out
there so we can tackle this issue
instead of just being silent about it
that's my manager
we just woke up 11
one of the brothers organized the
translated for us party message me in
the morning and he said that is kind of
flopped so it's not going to be coming
so right now we're in a bit of a dilemma
because the people here they don't speak
English and they just being just French
so we need to find the translator
otherwise we can we just can't do
anything kind of nothing here so what
we're gonna do is were in contact with a
couple of people just waiting for them
to give us updates what's going to
happen initially we'll trying to get I
translated chaga
desperate situation to do this but I
surely see what last ones has got
planned for us we're going to hit stains
right now and see what
[Music]
buddy
[Music]
firstly canoe canoe can you ask him what
what does he know about what happened
when I heard this that they published a
photo on video of the girl and it was
photoshopped and it made her look in an
appropriate situation and then people
start talking and start bullying her in
social networks in her neighborhood a
neighborhood and the streets and then
the girl she got really annoyed and she
was so desperate to the point that she
committed suicide I heard about this
from she had a sexual relationship with
her boyfriend sexual relationship with
her boyfriend video was published online
and it ended up in the hands of her
family so she was so desperate and she
took the decision to end her life and
say well what I heard is that she didn't
want to kill herself she just wanted to
hurt herself
not kill herself the she not does he
know that the video wasn't off her it
wasn't her does he know my Kenneth he
has a video and it brings my Canadians
the video kind of well some people say
it was her some people say it was not
her but I personally saw cyclone from
Facebook and I'm sure it was her but we
found out that it's not her me
personally I didn't see the video so I
cannot tell you if it was heard in the
video or not I heard it from a friends
and from the Bell from people here in
the neighborhood as I told you I
personally think it doesn't matter if it
was video do you know that basically
that video was a slander like it wasn't
her on the video okay but how is he how
how is can you ask him how is he so sure
that it was her Facebook account is just
guy over boyfriend okay okay okay let's
let's let's tell him that what we have
been told by the police and journalists
that the video is not of her who does he
think is responsible for her death I
think that the person will publish the
video or the photo in the first place
he's the one to blame
first of all all the people that spoke
about her all the people that bullied
her they are partners in this in this
crime you know what
they eventually ignored what al-qura
Hamid peace be open on him had
recommended us I will blame the people
who put the video on internet and true
or false we don't have to interfere
people with their business people life
understand so I disagree with that yeah
in my opinion I seen the people have
criticized 200 people people who just
and even and of course the pressure on
her in a way that she felt scared to
speak to them and she ended up by
killing herself anyone in our age will
feel scared in her situation no one can
judge what would you say the community
should have done instead of maybe it's a
no bullying yeah they should have stayed
quiet about it and have respect for her
and having a family and for them too
because it's the same code is it because
they're not like nobody knows hundred
percent what happened
[Music]
No yeah as far as I know nobody knows
Anderson like what would you what advice
would you give to the you know three
weeks ago a fourteen-year-old Muslim
girl called Aisha was accused of a lie
in a slander a video went viral and this
land was made against her but she
committed zina and the person in the
video was her and the community and her
and the people in the social media
turned against her and pushed her so far
that she had no choice but to commit
suicide as a way out my promise and
sisters I want to talk to you guys about
another I shot and this actually is very
dear to us it's the mother of the
believers
I should add the other one I shall run
our mother was slandered against when
she was traveling with the Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him on a journey
in a desert
unfortunately I shall reveal her and got
separated by the caravan and she was
lost
toggle of Allah a Sahaba by the name of
swan even wattle was going past and he
saw a shadow lower and he did not speak
anything except to bring his camel near
the camel down so I should under law and
can jump on the camel and so he can
catch up with a caravan when they
arrived at their destination the leader
of the hypocrites abdullah even obey saw
this started a slander a lie against the
mother of the believers these rumors and
these Lamas went on for a whole month
and when I shall add yellow hand heard
this she was so distressed she said that
she was she would cry every night she
would cry and she was in distress and
she didn't know what to do just as a
situation where many of the sisters
would be with the slander in the
following verses Alice once Allah talks
directly to those people who slandered
against I saw rayalu an and said those
amongst you why did they not make an
excuse why did they say you know what no
maybe it wasn't her any kind of excuse
made possible to clear her name and when
Alice want Allah send these verses down
he directly was conveying that message
to the people who started this London
accusations and Allah says in the Quran
all believing men and women why did you
not make good excuses for Aisha and only
I shot for anybody that gets pondered
why did you not feel good even if the
video is out or whatever it is
why did you not say you know what it's
not her it can't be her she wouldn't do
that why did you not make good excuses
for her and alice monsaert says in the
following verses why did they not bring
4 witnesses indeed if they are truthful
and not only that and Alice once Allah
says indeed you did not bring these
witnesses you are a liar in my eyes you
are a liar so this is what Allah so
Allah is harshly addressing those people
who do the slander and make every excuse
to blame the individual and following
the verses Allah so Allah says had it
not been my Grace and my mercy in this
life and the Hereafter indeed a severe
punishment would have fall upon you
while he was talking and slandering
saying things that you have no knowledge
of like it's something small
indeed Allah says for me what you did
was grave it was big in my sights why
did you not say when you heard indeed it
is not for me to talk about it's got
nothing to do with me and move away
Alice want Allah said in the final
verses I warn you that indeed if your
true believers do not repeat the same
thing again